Princess Mononoke was directed by Hayao
Miyazaki and is currently celebrating
its 20th anniversary in theaters it
showed most recently on the fifth and
it's going to be showing again on the
ninth in case you missed it and
naturally I want to review this movie
because it's a Studio Ghibli film and
Miyazaki is one of my favorite directors
of all time this film follows a young
prince who in the brilliant riveting
opening scene is attacked by a boar that
contains a demon inside of him and after
he comes in contact with this boar he
gets this strange rash around his arm
that gives him odd powers but also
causes him to be banished from his
village because now they view him as
unclean so he has to go out into the
world and discover it for the first time
which is where he comes across Princess
Mononoke a girl who lives with the
wolves and a war between nature and this
town led by a woman who's obsessed with
killing the spirit of the forest now I
feel like whenever I review a Studio
Ghibli movie I'm always going to
pinpoint one specific thing but there's
no escaping it the animation is fucking
brilliant this is one of the
best-looking Ghibli movies there is this
film came out in 1997 in Japan and it
was revolutionary for hand-drawn
animation I mean today when you see
films like Zootopia and up and Toy Story
3 and all these amazing animated films
you marvel at the computer animation and
it's it really is incredible what they
can do today but when you actually think
about the fact that people sat there
with pencils and pens and they painted
these hand-drawn cells and they animated
them to interact with each other and
they got the grit underneath their
fingernails and they wiped sweat from
their brow and you really think about
that the animation in this film becomes
all the more impressive because of the
way shadows interact with things the way
the trees can obscure things in the
background the wind moving through the
leaves the animation of the demon boar
in the opening scene what they
accomplished with this movie for its
time and still today it's breathtakingly
beautiful Princess Mononoke is one of my
favorite Ghibli films what's even more
impressive about this movie is that
Miyazaki rarely ever Helm's action
sequences most of his films are very
children friendly this film has a lot of
gore and a lot of action scenes and what
I took away from it this time
re-watching it a couple days ago is how
masterful the editing is Miyazaki's
timing is so on point with the editing
in this film to fully maximize visual aw
at what we're looking at and that's
something he captures wonderfully in
this movie a childlike sense of awe
despite the fact that we're watching a
slightly more mature film than Miyazaki
usually Helms there's still something
childlike and beautiful about his vision
for this world whenever our main
character sees the spirit of the forest
this large deer like creature you almost
get the sense that Miyazaki is showing
you a vision of heaven and that level of
wonderment is maintained throughout this
entire film something else I love about
this movie is iron town the depiction of
this city it feels like a workable
believable city you see the politics of
it you see the women and how they
control things and you see the men and
how they control things you understand
how this city is able to prosper a lot
of times in anime and especially movies
people just wander across a big
prosperous town and the film takes no
time to explain how this town is even a
thing
but in this film you understand what
these people are after how they all work
together to get it and how this town
specifically relates to the opening
scene with the bored demon monster and
you understand how everything ties
together but the main message that I
think Miyazaki is trying to get across
in this movie is that man is at war with
nature and that nature isn't doing
anything about it
yet but if nature did and nature fought
back we'd be completely screwed and
although it can get a little preachy at
times and slightly heavy-handed it's a
message that in 1997 needed to be heard
I mean when you look at today I know
everyone talks about nature and how we
need to protect the environment imagine
when this film came out 20 years ago and
this was what Miyazaki was trying to
preach then the guy was ahead of his
time he knew exactly what he was doing
this is a brilliant fantastic animation
film it truly is a remarkable thing to
look at it's hard sometimes to separate
just how visually beautiful this movie
is with trying to focus on the story but
I've seen it so many times now that I
can do that and Princess Mononoke is one
of my all-time favorite Studio Ghibli
films and I'm going to
and a guy's like I said it's going to be
showing once more in theaters this month
dubbed in English On January 9th look
forward to that if you want to see in
theaters you can get your tickets now
because it is worth it guys thank you so
much as always for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]
you